radikale klimaaktivisten sie blockieren
straßen besetzen unternehmen verteidigen
will dagegen abholzungen ihr mittel
ziviler ungehorsam sie sagen ihre
aktionen sind gewaltfrei trotzdem
brechen sie bewusst gesetzte
münchen es ist fünf uhr 30 die stadt
erwacht heute hat hier extinction
rebellion eine aktion angekündigt es ist
mitte mai gut einen monat vor dem g7
gipfel die klimaaktivisten susanne egli
ist sich bewusst dass sie straftaten
begeht
kalkulieren auf jeden fall ein dass wir
festgenommen werden und das nehmen wir
auch im drauf das natürlich nicht schön
aber
bisher ist es immer relativ glimpflich
ausgegangen also bisher seien keine ins
gefängnis gekommen und wir hoffen
natürlich dass es auch so bleibt
6 uhr die aktivisten sind am ziel die
zentrale des größten rückversicherers
der welt
die balustrade haben susanne egli und
anderen mitstreiter schon besetzt dann
beginnt die eigentliche aktion
so früh am morgen sind wenig
schaulustige unterwegs doch das macht
den aktivisten nichts es gibt ja noch
die digitalen medien
ich stelle das mit youtube ins internet
und das wird dementsprechend viele
klicks bekommen auch die
straßenblockaden der gruppe aufstand der
letzten generation werden im netz
übertragen sie kleben sich mit
sekundenkleber auf straßenfest
blockieren so den verkehr
viele autofahrer sind sauer
einige werden handgreiflich
das passiert nicht jedes mal meist läuft
es ab wie hier in brandenburg
aktivisten vom aufstand der letzten
generation blockieren ein unternehmen
von dem öl einer russischen pipeline an
abnehmer in der ganzen gegend geliefert
wird im moment steht alles genau das ist
das ziel
wir richten uns jetzt auch nicht an die
einzelnen leute um ihnen das leben
schwer zu machen wir sagen einfach wir
müssen das mal unterbrechen damit wir
alle aufhorchen und dieses aufhorchen
das muss eben in kurzer zeit geschehen
weil wir sonst keine kleine schnitte
mehr haben aufrütteln durch illegale
aktionen der philosoph und jurist felix
ekardt beschäftigt sich seit langem mit
der klimabewegung sie sei zwar laut aber
insgesamt bewege sie in der gesellschaft
wenig ziviler ungehorsam für mehr
klimaschutz kann dazu führen dass
menschen so er noch bockiger werden noch
wieder weniger klimaschutz belangen
gehen mittlerweile bleibt es aber nicht
nur bei straßenblockaden
seit einigen wochen drehen aktivisten
bundesweit öffentlich zugängliche rohöl
pipelines ab
die klimabewegung steckt in einem
dilemma tadzio müller ist politologe und
ein vordenker des klima aktivismus hat
die anti kohle bewegung ende gelände mit
gegründet für ihn sind alle
klimakonferenzen gescheitert sie hätten
die klimaschädlichen treibhausgase nicht
entscheidend gestoppt müller fordert
mehr statt weniger radikalität
das wäre ethisch und politisch rational
denn die aktions radikalisieren ich
mache aktivismus seit langem so offen
wie möglich ich werde zeigen dass wir
machen das sollte vernünftig wenn die
sachen blockieren denn das gesetz
brechen das ist richtig eine radikale
einschätzung drückte müller den wunsch
vieler klima aktivisten aus oder
übertreibt er der erst kürzlich
veröffentlichte verfassungsschutzbericht
gibt entwarnung nur vereinzelt
versuchten linke extremisten die
klimabewegung zu unterwandern die
meisten aktivisten lehnen gewalt ab
zivile widerstand
keinesfalls gewalt anwenden dann der
dann würden wir sozusagen in einem ganz
anderes raster umkippen und da gilt es
ihm sehr sorgfältig die verschiedenen
aktionsform zu prüfen und das machen wir
auch
dass es
erstaunlich dass in dem moment
wie eine gesetzesübertretung begeben die
frage sofort im raum steht ob das jetzt
gewalt sei das ist eigentlich eine
erstaunliche frage gut und frieling ist
human biologen sie gehört zur gruppe
scientist rebellion in der
wissenschaftler gegen den klimawandel
protestieren heute kleistern sie
klimastudien an die fenster einer
deutschen bank filiale mit diesem
gesetzesbruch werfen sie der bank vor
weiter milliarden in geschäfte mit
fossilen energieträgern zu investieren
in dem die
investitionen in fossile energien
pariser konvention 2015 81 milliarden
euro hinter eingeflossen und damit
finanziert sie im prinzip den tod nach
einigen minuten müssen die
wissenschaftler die bank verlassen zu
ende ist die aktion trotzdem nicht jetzt
wird die filiale von außen blockiert was
aus sicht der aktivisten ziviler
ungehorsam ist bedeutet für die bank
sachbeschädigung und kosten für die
reinigung am ende kommt die polizei den
zugang zur bankfiliale
auch bei susanne egli ist inzwischen die
polizei eingetroffen sie kam zu spät um
die aktion bei der im juni gri zu
verhindern für die aktivisten war sie
daher ein voller erfolg auch weil
genügend pressevertreter gekommen sind
ob das gefühl benutzt auch die presse so
ein bisschen für eure ziele und naja ich
glaube das ist ein geben und nehmen die
presse benutzt und relativ steil also es
hat ja jeder was davon dass er war
natürlich brauchen wir die presse dass
er hat eine ganz wichtige rolle
darüber zu berichten was falsch läuft
susanne egli und die in anderen droht
eine anzeige unter anderem wegen
hausfriedensbruch und sachbeschädigung
wie weit darf protest gehen jede gruppe
hat hier ihre eigene antwort die
vorstellungen von dem was angesichts der
klimakrise noch angemessen ist gehen
auseinander